bonsoir patrick n une scène merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt français
d'avoir patienté l'armée israélienne
annonce au soir renforcer sa présence en
cisjordanie près de la bande de gaza
avec des troupes de combat c'était déjà
le cas quelques jours avant dans la
vallée du jourdain est ce que le plan
est déjà finalement mis en oeuvre avant
même d'être acceptée et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs rejetée par les palestiniens
grâce à une fausse
je pense qu'ils sont déjà en train de
l'appliquer bof on était déjà en oeuvre
depuis plusieurs générations
c'est cette une politique israélienne de
mener sous les radars une politique nous
ont déclaré des objectifs
ils ont déclaré qu israël connaissait
bien je te dis que les palestiniens je
connaissais bien mais qui avait échappé
tout est resté invisible invisible pour
le reste du monde pour les journaux et
pour washington où on ne parle pas de ce
genre de choses les palestiniens savent
bien que c'est faux tickets sont en
cours depuis des décennies maintenant et
même au cours du processus de paix
d'oslo
au cours des trois derniers de la poule
mathieu s'est au sto 2.0 relance ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 90 au début
des années 2000 accord en fin de compte
elle vise à être rejeté par les
palestiniens
ceux qui l'ont déjà fait auparavant
israël et les états unis you re la
murray les palestiniens pour leur rejet
via l'accord totalement acceptable pour
washington
alors donateurs mais hier en tout cas à
vente et son super d'ilan en exhortant
les palestiniens
l accepter leur disant c'est votre seule
chance d'avoir un état indépendant est
ce qu'il faut croire une partie de son
discours au moins les palestiniens
peuvent-ils y croire selon vous maison
blanche s'est fait recette
israël mais nous attriste ce n'est pas
un accord cet âge de six matchs pour les
palestiniens à accepter cela c'est votre
dernière chance
l'annexion de la cisjordanie est en
cours de manière très agressive et il y
aura sans doute de lavage de la knesset
pour un excès 30 % de la cisjordanie
supplémentaires cela suit bon tu vois
les méthodes des états unis s'agissant
de saper le duc tomas teralys mais en
règle générale afin de décrédibiliser
des résolutions selon lui cela sorti
tout à fait à cette situation
move s'est montré très agressif dans la
colonisation des territoires occupés ou
des territoires que trop version
quelques temps qu'étaient les
résolutions adoptées à l'international
processus d'oslo de migros colonisateur
italien de temps ces régions sous biard
et s'il a changé la situation sur le
terrain et cela va continuer de la sorte
lorsqu'il ya des négociations une
difficile au niveau international
roger palestine
prend du temps la situation quand on
évolue sur le terrain israël
legault on commence tous les territoires
occupés sur le plateau du golan et en
cisjordanie ou dans la vallée du
jourdain ajouté valentin et ils vont
continuer et quels que soient les
besoins et les demandes des palestiniens
à leur demande d'accepter une solution à
deux états alors que tous les experts
tous les commentateurs je comprenne bien
que la solution à deux états que nous
qu'une arnaque pour va des militants de
gauche et cela depuis le net j'ai
d'avenir série de négociations de la
solution deux états est déjà morte
l'état palestinien
ils disent que peut-être à venir il
pourrait avoir un état mais vous devez
moi je veux bien payer à toutes ces
demandes ce n'est pas à un accord c'est
un ultimatum
merci beaucoup aux patrick hansen nous
avoir apporté en tout cas votre point de
vue en direct sur rt france dans vu de
l'extérieur ce soir